yeah
and now before we start we're together
to make silence
so everybody
[Music]
[Music]
good evening everyone
um
chair and definitely a licensing
committee and
Street trading is governed by the local
governments miscellaneous Provisions act
1982 schedule for a local Authority can
charge a fee for a street trading
consent to allow the sale of any article
in a consented Street traffic Council
prohibits Street trading on certain
streets and requires Street trading
consents to be obtained for the sale of
Articles from public land the
legislation also allows the consent to
be obtained for the sale of Articles
from private land to which the public
have access without payment Trafford
Council does not currently require a
consent to obtain in respect of private
land
there's currently no policy in place for
Street trading in Trafford and there are
guidance notes to assist applicants and
conditions which are attached to the
consent
members agreed that the previous
subcommittee meeting in June that a
28-day consultation period should take
place to introduce a new Street trading
policy including conditions and fees in
relation to the street trading consent
including ensuring that a street trading
consent is obtained where a Trader sales
exposes or offers for sale any article
in any non-prohibited Street within the
borough to which the public have access
without payment including private land
members also agreed that the meeting to
delegate to the chair of the
subcommittee and the licensing team
leader the consideration of the
responsible response responses to the
consultation
if the chairman team leader determined
that any of the consultation responses
were significant that they will be
brought back to the public protection
subcommittee for consideration and to
determine whether action is required
a large number of responses to the
consultations were received all along
the same lines but outlining significant
issues which needed to be brought back
to the subcommittee for consideration
and to determine what further action as
outlined in the report
the most
um detailed response was from the
Keystone solicitors which is attached as
at appendix 3. a number of similar
responses were also received in relation
to the impact the changes would have on
the most Match Day charity store
and the main concerns raised are under
the new policy proposals in order to
contain continue to trade on the private
land the Traders would need to apply for
a license and pay for the appropriate
fee however nearly all trading on
private land at mufc it takes place on
land um
to so Matt Busby way so Matt Busby way
is prohibited streets and under the
proposed policy we could not issue a
consent for trading on private land in
this location
and whilst there is also no fee increase
proposed under the policy no explanation
has been given as to how these fees have
been calculated for example it's not
clear why the costs for training in the
vicinity of Manchester United are higher
than in any other location in Trafford
or why costs for food licenses are
higher in the merchandise um trade for
merchandise Traders
in light of the consultation received
and the impact on livelihood this will
have um on this comment trading on
private land to which the public have
access by um adjacent to the prohibited
streets we are proposing to withdraw the
draft policy outlined in the reports
subcommittee in June 2022 which was
subject to the consultation
a full review of this we're proposing a
full review of the street trading
process including redesigning the
prohibited streets determining fees and
review of the premium non-premium food
and souvenir pictures around the
Manchester United area and in sale Town
Center will also be carried out as part
of the review we will consult with
highways greater Manchester police and
any other partners on when the proposed
changes will impact a further report
will then be brought before the
subcommittee ask information permission
to formally consult to the proposed fees
and charges and the proposed policy and
changes it will bring
the recommendations outlined in the
reporter one that the members agree to
the draft report policy outlined in the
reports of subcommittee in June 2010 to
attached its appendix one being
withdrawn two that the members agreed to
a full review of the street trading
process including consultation with
partners and three that members agree to
a further report being brought to the
subcommittee after the review has been
taken place outline a new proposed
policy and fees and charges for the full
consultation thank you
inside
doesn't really have any questions
[Music]
we have any idea about the time scale
um we're going to start the review
process as of tomorrow if this if it's
agreed to be withdrawn and so and now
it's it's going to take it will take a
while to probably do that consultation
because we want to engage all the
partners agencies and in the process of
and also get finalized and actually
understand the the fees and charges
around the Manchester area and
understand why we're charging what we're
charging
so there'll need to be a full scope out
and then concert them will come back for
a consultation
yes
yeah
um
thanks chip this is obviously a very
important process yes absolutely totally
in agreement with the recommendations
just one little nickel yeah
is this delay deferment whatever we want
to call it going to have any impact and
effect on the people who are currently
trading at various points on Matt Busby
way on Warwick Road you mean in the
future or now now now now no it'll
revert back to how it was so no there's
no impact at all we will do the review
as and start again from it's basically
starting again from scratch to do the
review consult with highways consult
with the greater Manchester police and
reconsider those prohibited streets
which were which you know there's been a
developing area since they were created
in the 1800s so we want to make sure
that we get that right in terms of those
prohibited streets it might be that we
look at conditions attached to those
those prohibited streets but yeah we
want to do a thorough review so we yeah
it came out that that that's the process
we want to do so we'll move that back
thank you for that I did not in
agreement with development since the
1800s country to popular belief I don't
remember
[Laughter]
thank you yeah I mean I can I'd agree to
bring you back in just a couple of
questions regarding mainly Keystone
Law's letter
um
rejecting any insignificant objections
worries me how do who determines which
is insignificant because objection is an
objection and is significant to the
person that brings it now obviously if
it's uh well I I brush the Pavements I
should
uh be able to charge be able to trade
from my from garden
free of charge that's it I didn't
significant arrived when I get out but
there are there will be some who's
deciding which is insignificant and
charging for people living in the do we
would we do that anywhere else in the
borough
it's looking at the Bullet Hole it's not
going to be just Manchester United that
we will look at we will look at the
whole of the borough in terms of those
prohibited streets and anything around
the yeah the borough is it's not just
that's why we want to look at it as a
whole in terms of those fees and charges
and look at it as a as above wide we
also wanted to do some benchmarking as
well of standardized prices yeah
standardized pricing and and make sure
and justify why we charge what we charge
and there is there has been um
consultation in the past over it we
can't unfortunately I can't find that
document it's my brain disletters so I
want to make sure that we have got it
right that what we're charging is
proportionate to to to to to what we're
charging and and we look at though that
okay and obviously with the English
charges enforcement on Street trading
with our license I.E specifically at
places like Old Trafford like the
cricket ground women's concerts on
because
so many people Milling around there so
one of the biggest things that we've not
we don't haven't taken into account is
enforcement costs which is something
that we are looking at across the board
in terms of different different areas of
Licensing regimes and this will be one
that we will look at in terms of the
enforcement practices that and the
enforcement work that we need to do in
order to deliver that it will also look
at the process inside as well so we want
to scope out and time learn what the
officers do inside internally that they
need to do and the time it takes them
and the costings around that and then
we'll also look at the costings of
enforcement as well to actually enforce
that that street trading because yeah it
just the concern is that we're we're
raising the prices to up we all said at
the time were Fair bad costs and
reasonable I think we have we have
raised the the price in in terms of
Street trading fairly recently but we
haven't done this year no no I'm just
saying I'm saying that the prices are
are why I would term reasonable but
they're not reasonable if we're not
enforcing on concerts and football
matches where people are selling posters
t-shirts that are not there that that
would for the trademark that would fall
under the difference trading standards
of regime which is a different regime to
this the licensing regime in terms of
the um but those that pay could complain
that they're in a license and we're
doing nothing to stop I completely
understand that yet and that's something
that we would factor in in terms of
enforcement we also have license and
enforcement which will be able to
enforce the the provisions of what they
do in terms of the licenses okay thank
you okay
um you say that you had a large number
of responses I just wondered if you had
as many as you would have expected and
if not would you be taking this
opportunity to extend those responses
um we had um a large number I think from
within determining the it was 50 plus
objections in terms of it
um when we we realized what the the the
content of those objections were to it
was going to affect those livelihoods
which is not what we intended in terms
of the policy the detention is was to
was to bring in and cost recovery in
terms of the service and not to to
damage livelihoods in terms of and being
able to trade along that street which is
something that we've we've held our
hands up and said that we needed to go
back to the to look at that prohibited
street because it would have prohibited
them from Trading along that street so
we deemed that was significant enough
because we didn't want to stop them from
Trading there isn't enough because we
have conditional pictures already along
those streets when match day is but they
didn't we didn't have enough of those
pictures to be able to remove those into
those relevant pictures which we could
have done and as opposed to we did we
decided that let's pull the policy go
back to the drawing board in terms of
the the prohibited streets and we can
address this going forward and look at
the fees and charges and what we do
actually charge and whether they are
proportionate in terms of those
particular you know those particular
um uh Street trading pictures
yeah
thank you chair just one on the uh
on private land that you've mentioned
just clarification as to those
uh
have they been consulted in has there
been any responses back from them on the
previous case you know was it just still
taken for granted on the previous
occasion to this policy being brought
yes yeah um the the consultation
previously and they we didn't need to
because they didn't pay for a license so
they actually they actually had to was
situated on land that was adjacent to
the prohibited streets so effectively
there was trading over into the
prohibitor street which is something
which we can which we can charge for
um if we if we've got the red relevant
conditions attached to those those
streets but
um
it's they weren't consulted on because
we never had that that need to to do
that we do we do engage with them when
we're walking down the streets and our
officers enforcement staff have engaged
with them they have had conversations
with them in the past in terms of what
they're selling and things like that in
terms of trading standards and stuff and
they will hold also food registration
licenses Etc as well as along those
streets but the engagement was done
through the consultation process and we
did engage throughout that consultation
process by issuing a letter writing to
them and then we've had as I say all
these responses in terms of that
consultation to bring that policy
forward
yeah yeah
I I mean I'm very glad that we got a lot
of uh responses I'm I'm glad that we've
listened I mean that is a positive
um many of the responses do raise
um small sellers Peddlers really now
when we talked about this last meeting
you you clearly said this does not cover
the Peddler's act however we've got this
new document that I didn't see last time
which is the council meeting from 2008
which is on page 59
section 58 on page 59 Section 3 the
effects of the introduction of proposal
to be monitored measured and to control
unlicensed trading activity to reduce
Hawker and Peddler activity in the area
so I just want to make doubly sure we
aren't aiming to try and curb what is
the right of someone that has that
license
no we we've intent the intention is is
to do the right enforcement and get this
right and that's why we've we've pulled
this policy because we recognize that
this wouldn't get it right it would we
need to go back to to reviewing how we
go forward in terms of this
um
and we do need to enforce against those
Peddlers they do need to be moved on in
terms of the when they are here they
that that their license is a significant
difference in price in terms of what
they have and their license is intended
that they move from Street to street now
unfortunately that legislation is 1800s
again in terms of so we have to
determine that legislation to the modern
to the modern world in terms of those
licenses and we try our utmost best in
terms of those enforcement practices
that we do carry out around the Peddlers
Street trading is a completely different
thing in its entity it's completely set
aside to to Peddlers Peddlers are
designed to move from Street to Street
they carry their goods with them they're
supposed to keep moving and they move
from City to city that is what a
Peddler's license is is is is is about a
street trading pitch and a street
trading consent is designed to stay in
the same place in the same location
which is what is a completely different
type of license
the city to City thing doesn't sound
right in the fact that to be a peddler I
have to live in in an area greater
Manchester I have to live here to apply
to Greater management for that license
so I don't understand how I would then
walk on to Liverpool to trade there it
doesn't make any sense to me that but
I'll go and read the ACT it's a nice the
ACT is an old act it's that's what it
was intended of that so it doesn't need
yeah it's thank you I appreciate that
[Music]
I just wondered if
um and again thank you for undertaking
this consultation and and uh responding
to um the the issues that have been
raised
um is there are there any models of
practice in other boroughs who have sort
of similar predicaments that that we do
know that they've got a major event
premises like we have and you know this
sort of issue where some people are
trading on private land some people
trade in them when we did the original
consultation we looked out of
neighboring and we did benchmarking in
terms of what other neighboring
authorities did and we we aimed that
policy in line with what a lot of the
other greater Manchester authorities
were doing and all the large those that
hold larger scale
um venues like we do
um
all of those do not have the the same
issue in terms of what we have in that
they do charge for those that sit on
private land
um we are in a we are we are out of that
in terms of that we don't so that that's
what there was the intention to bring
back into terms of the policy was to
bring that in line with with what other
greater manager authorities were doing
but what we've done in terms of that is
the recognition of this this
consultation has made us realize that by
doing that we would put people out of
business and I and that is not the
intention of the policy and and now and
never was the intention
um what we want to do is we want we we
need to we so that's why we need to go
back and review our prohibited streets
review the policy in terms of how we
deliver that and the consent around
those policies so that we can bring this
policy back so that it in the same sort
of similar elk but also have the regard
for those prohibited streets and
reassess those streets and maybe put
conditions attached to those
um prohibited streets so that we can we
can bring this policy in is again before
you in its way that it is
um going forward
yeah
I think just a quick one on the on the
pricing thing there's this one day event
license which is price on application
this is some kind of formula are you
using that's the problem we don't have
formulas a set aside um to I I've tried
to investigate how they were they were
calculated in the past and I have tried
to uncover where the report was and
which worked out that um formula into
towards those costings unfortunately I
don't have have that document to hand I
can't find that document in our archives
so that is another reason why I think
it's wise that we go back to to looking
at that formula how it's worked out and
look at as a whole going forward what we
can do in terms of the fees and charges
and pricing and actually have something
set out in writing that we we understand
the formula as to how we've calculated
those fees
yep yeah
foreign the objection to charging
because it's on private land I think we
have to make a distinction that it's not
actually ground rent we're charging it's
a licensing fee you know for the running
of the the licensing regime and
enforcement and everything just as you
would in a pub or a taxi which are all
privately owned so I think that would
you know nullify the objection that
while you're charging
for for us to trade off private land
it's not the actual land it's the it's
the actual licensing fee licensing
regime that um that they're actually
paying for
um so any no further questions
in that case if we were asked to agree
the recommendation
three recommendations that we agreed to
withdraw the uh the policy that we that
was agreed on the 30th of June 2022
that we agreed to a full review of the
street trading process including seeking
the views of internal external partners
are number three that members agree to
further report being brought to the
public protection subcommittee following
the review with a revised proposed
policy purple consultation
so can we agree those recommendations
yeah okay thank you that's agreed so
thank you Claire I'll let you go
foreign
so now we're going to do item four
which is the no sorry item three which
is the uh the penalty points system
again we're gonna have to we're
re-looking at this because of the
new conditions that were passed by the
council last year
that correct in relation to the minimum
standards
so obviously you Joanne thanks Jeff
um
so traffic Council has had a penalty
point scheme since 1992 I think actually
they were the Forerunner of this kind of
scheme
um the system was devised to give
officers and the subcommittee additional
options where a license holder
has breached conditions and is not
considered it's not considered
appropriate perhaps to revoke the
license because in most cases where
there's a breach of conditions the only
options available to the committee are
to
either do nothing or to suspend or to
revoke and in certain sectors you might
not want to do that
um so this report is to ask the
subcommittee to consider the proposed
penalty points policy
which has has been revised to reflect
the new conditions which were adopted by
the council last year
these conditions around new drivers
vehicles and operators
um subcommittee is being asked to
consider the report and affirm the
procedure
for issuing points and to approve the
revised table now officers have put
forward
sets you know the actual points and and
ordered them
um but this is very much
for the committee to decide what they
think is important because in in effect
you might be issuing these points
um you know in as opposed to suspension
or revocation of the license so they're
just we're offering up suggestions on
um the points to award to breaches so
each of the breaches relates to a
condition on the license for a driver
vehicle owner or operator
um I have left
um some sheets out for you because we've
noticed that that
um we've we had failed to include
certain ones that we thought were
important
um and we've actually revised one breach
that we think is it's more important you
know that their points should be higher
so
um if you look at the sheet that I left
on your your your in front of you
um
we've moved failure to notify change of
address from 25 points up to 75 points
um because obviously we've
if we want to serve
notice on somebody if we want to reform
them of changes of policy or conditions
it's important that we know where people
are living so that we can write to them
um so it is important that they do
notify yours within a reasonable period
of time
when they've changed address
um we noticed also that we hadn't
included
fairly to notify the name of operator or
change when they change and operate and
we are finding
um that when we're chasing drivers who
um have been contacted to be told that
their license has been suspended uh they
have 21 days in which to appeal at the
point at that point after that 21 days
we need to to get the the badge back and
another action we take is to notify the
operator so they don't give them any
further work and we're finding when we
contact operators a lot of the time they
say oh this person hasn't worked for me
for three years so it's it's a bit of a
frustration so we want to it is a
conditional license uh the driver's
license so
um we had forgotten to include that as a
um
a policy point it might be that you know
certainly
um it's not something that we would
necessarily report to you but it's
something that officers can issue and
penalty points for and if that's
a regular
um activity you know issue with that
particular drive then it will come back
it will come to this committee for you
to decide whether or not that person is
continues to be fit and proper to hold a
license
so I'm happy to talk to you about any of
the points if you want to amend any of
the points to you once you feel that one
breach is should be considered less of
an offense
uh or it might be that you think it
needs to have more points I'm happy to
discuss that
thanks Dave what methodology did you use
to arrive at the
The Matrix you got in front of us
[Music]
no just wondering how you got this this
is this is basically just a um
opinion for wants of a better word just
but just an assessment of what you think
is the most most serious offenses
[Music]
ultimately it's just a matter of
personal opinion isn't it really
well within within reason yeah
thank you so forgive me because I'm new
to this committee because it's going to
be a bit of a newbie question I didn't
know we had these penalty points this
this system at all
um do we have Israel basis and law as a
president to this
um for when someone racks up the points
and then we're calling them in we could
easily suspend the license from there
we'll go to a they may appeal to the
local Court to get it back do we have
legal precedence to success for this
internal monitories
and it was the same with you guys
know our manager and as I say it was to
allow some kind of options missing from
having to take about those ultimate
decisions are do people do you love them
give you suspense
will be quite harsh for over each other
it's not told that it's where he's
living
no matter wants to revolved
hmm
so it was developed into another it's
been
um where I'd be to the licensing
conference
inspired conference where they talk
about having an event
as of where your keeping more options
so it's something that's grown in
popularity
foreign
simply something this Council has
developed so without
other options
in terms of terms of sanctions it's also
I think useful if if ultimately you make
a decision to revolutionize license
based on the fact that they are
continually contributed conditions they
might be small you know they might
vulnerability minor conditions that
something is continually reaching them
show this is why it's not just based
technology
preaching dishes has no regard
and we can kind of we can evidence that
so it's just again it's not
thank you
I think my question sort of Builds on
that really so it's not based in law and
this is something specific to Trafford
there's not a tool that's used
nationally I mean obviously we're moving
towards greater monster regulation
aren't we is there anything again in
existence in other boroughs that's
that's like this so you know we might
consider rightly that failure to help
somebody who's a wheelchair user is a is
a serious misdemeanor isn't it whereas
that might get judged differently in a
different world might enter in a or pure
yet because it is our penalty point
scheme so we can choose how how what
um points we give and took for what
breaches of condition I know that lots
of authorities have a penalty point
scheme but it may be completely
different to ours they might have as you
say they might think
um a particular breach is is much more
serious than we do
um so there isn't one template really
that does surprise me somewhat because
you know things like
um
you know adherence to to traffic
regulations or the
um
you know they're Universal aren't they
or the certainly National aren't they
you know if you remember we're talking
about these are linked to the conditions
which are attached to the driver's
license now our conditions of license
may be different from Monsters driver
condition I mean as greater Manchester
we have adopted these sets of conditions
so all greater Manchester authorities
have adopted these conditions
um I'm not aware I'm not sure that my
colleagues in other authorities have got
a penalty point scheme some of them may
have
um I think one or two of them do have
the rationale for having it I'm just
surprised that it's not something that's
a little bit more universally utilized
or this isn't a tool that you know is is
used you know I know that when I've been
doing the licensing conference when they
have the sessions the um the person who
developed it here Andy Eaton
um he's worked for a number of Licensing
authorities he often goes he often does
these sessions where he's saying he's
trying to persuade other authorities why
it's a good thing and
um and I know that there is a lot of
interest in in having such a a device to
support members decisions
um so it's I wouldn't I mean I wouldn't
say it's only traffic that has no points
the tool is unique to Trafford yeah we
we we designed it originally and
um it has been taken up by other
authorities for instance other
authorities might have you know they
might just have a over like one to ten
in terms of their points and
um but it's it's
it's right it's mainly around the
conditions of license so that
you don't have to be faced with a choice
of do nothing suspend or revoke a person
when you're looking at quantifying
doesn't it the the yeah
this is a fluid document at any you know
we can change as as we report people to
you say for breaches of condition
um
you you know it may we may just you may
decide that you want to
um give if for instance you decide
um that you want to give more points to
a particular offense that's something we
can we we can because it's our document
we can we can change that easily a
driver's made aware of this when they
um are issued with the license are they
aware that this this schemes in
existence yeah so it's on our websites
yeah and the old scheme is on the
website and when you apply online for a
license you can see all the relevant
documents so you're you're kind of
signposted to all the information that
we have around our policies and
procedures so it's included there
um and on the training session for new
drivers it's referred to there as well
so it wouldn't come as a surprise to
somebody then if they said we've used
this means of
sort of evaluation you're not familiar
with it because we haven't used it for
some time when we do it obviously in the
off in the back office so often officers
are issuing penalty points because
get a lot of failure to notify a change
of address so that we there is a
delegate under the Delta scheme of
Delegation officers
um can issue penalty points up to 150
penalty points at that point it must be
referred we're saying it should be
referred to you for you to decide
whether somebody remains fit and proper
um you can change any of that if you
want to
um if you feel that
um somebody should be allowed more
points before they're referred to you
um we're happy to
to adopt anything that you
know you feel needs to be changed about
what we're proposing
because it in essence is your document
it's your
thank you
thank you
um I I endorse this I think is a great
idea I would like to be
incorporated into presentations when
people are brought before the committee
so it gives us an idea of how
they have
behaved under the terms of the license
going forward I've got a couple of
couple of quick issues if a vehicle on
the vehicle side if the penalty points
are on the vehicles is it the driver or
the tracker if the vehicle is a tracked
vehicle is it to the owner of the
vehicle or is it the person that's in
the vehicle that their points would be
we often give it to both okay
in the past we have
um I think some of them will cross over
you know in terms of failure of
conditions and primarily it was it's the
vehicle owner is responsible for the
conditions of the vehicle yeah
it's been a large sort of money to track
a vehicle for a week it is part of that
money I would assume the vehicle owner
said I track out my vehicle I never look
at it
um they still have a responsibility to
make sure it's um roadworthy and meets
all the conditions of license
but
we might then also look at if that's
being tracked out and it's the driver
who has it and it's parked outside their
house and we have conditions around
doing daily checks
which there are on the on the vehicle
conditions then we might then
say well that driver is breached those
conditions and we might miss your points
to my mind it would tone up if the
driver had notified and is provably
notified the the tracker or the owner
then he should be able to do that uh
also whilst one point Vehicles
personally I think uh defective tires
fail to maintain the vehicle and go
mechanical and structural condition
varying and mechanical instructional
specification I think they're too low
particularly with defensive lights let
me just get the ones
I thought I printed them out but
[Music]
um
um for some reason the vehicle ones
didn't come out on my printer let me
just
so I just want to make sure that I've
got them
um
any changes that you might want to
incorporate
yeah I'd like them
Look So you you're talking about
Vehicles it's yeah it's the first two
right so failed to pertain the vehicle
in good and mechanical and structural
condition at all times yeah I would I
would rather be at least 100 points in
this in this structure okay is that is
that something everybody
oh there's there's a few of you want me
to
sorry no no it's fine I mean it's as I
say it's your
your device your plan
so that you want that to be 100
similarly with the variation of
structure and spec
okay
um defective tires
again that's a pointable offense and
it's dangerous to the people within the
taxi
75 is that further down further down
further down about uh
just below mid oh yeah I see it so you
would want that to be I don't get
nothing though because it impinges on
the safety of the passengers basically
so I would like that to see a hundred
okay and defective lights whilst they
can go whilst on a trip and you wouldn't
know I'd like to see that go up to 50
because again the daily checks should
mean that they're up to 50 for that one
yeah for my mind yes yeah on operators
uh I do think the operators go up a
little bit lightly on the scoring scheme
but there's nothing I can really do a
check but in conjunction with
um
failing to notify the name of operator
change change of operator and The
Operators
um required to provide us with the
licensed drivers
so anytime we can ask an operator to
confirm who is working through them and
and they need to provide was
um evidence so records
um and we can do we can go in and do
spot checks as well
um and ask to see their driver records
well they're not they're not actually
required to tell us so if I no I work
for streetcars and I went to Passenger
cars I have to tell you and if I don't
I'm going to get
100.75 points but the operators have no
response yeah there's not a condition
that requires them to do to do that
perhaps I could look at that in the
future not not within this document and
finally on the drivers
um
the second one conveying a greater
number of passengers and permitted I
think that should be 150 because that
negates the insurance of the vehicle
uh failure to ensure the safety of
passengers which is whilst it's a a very
wide encompassing statement to make
again I would like to see our eyes I
don't really know why I think where I
think that should go because it's very
difficult to see a definition just about
seven or eight down below failure to
notify the name of operator change your
operator is 75 points at the moment okay
[Music]
I'll find out sorry bear with me
about a third of the way down yeah but
maybe halfway
just when you just don't see something
yeah so the last one before it widens up
under 75 this is unoperated no drivers
drivers sorry yeah I'm on driving
it's just just below smoking in a
license uh vehicle ah okay
about 15
19. you know when you can't say
something just looking at something
you're going to see it
Dave if you gave me the wrong
information
is mine different to you
on drivers can you point it out to me
I think I'm going blind
there you go oh there it is that one
that one that writes
apologies
so you're not sure again what you might
want to I I wouldn't like it I mean it
could be 150 it would be intermediate
yeah reporting to you at the end of the
day it's such a wide thing failing to
ensure a safety passage it could be many
things couldn't it yeah but the main
thing about this committee is that when
they're brought
in front of the committee as a firm
proper person who's around the safety of
passengers so I just think that we can
speak a little bit and and finally there
are
a couple of pointable offenses within
the drivers stopping waiting on zigzags
or outside of school
um that's pointable events
um concealing or defacing a vehicle
license the only reason they're going to
do that is for
um
so I think those will come about you
know because we sometimes we get a lot
of complaints about and yeah outside
schools
exactly at three points when I was 19 I
fell foul of that but with my rear wheel
on a Saturday evening on a zigzag and I
got three points and a large fine for it
so what I'm getting is on the drive is I
agree broadly except for those but where
there's a criminal offense or a driving
event sorry uh involved that you should
you know to Karen to passengers or other
Road users
you know it's the these are potentially
criminal offenses which possibly should
uh sorry
be more weighted okay we only would only
take two if we did 7500 because it would
that be for them to be reported to you
is that something you just my opinion
across across the board I think it's a
good idea I'm just happy to increase
that if that's it
and that's that's it for me thank you
um yeah I just noticed there's two two
mentions of driving uh sorry smoking on
the driver's bet smoking on use of an
e-cigarette and smoking a licensed
vehicle at any time I know somebody else
mentioned that I don't know why that
we've got the two I did have a look try
to have a look at the conditions and I
don't know why because what I did was go
through all the conditions and then you
know list them so
um
I'm not sure why it's there twice
because I think I think because we're
distinguishing between an e-cigarette
and smoking
um
because we View
both of them to be equally a very you
know a breach because
so we included both smoking and
e-cigarette and smoking a cigarette
as
um equal you know as an offense as a
condition you can't smoke a cigarette
and you can't smoke an e-cigarette in a
vehicle because it's so difficult to it
would be so difficult to know whether or
not you were actually smoking a
cigarette or you were smoking music
foreign
[Laughter]
was about the use of the mobile phone
electronic device
I don't know what you actually mean by
use of it because
clearly people do use them for finding
their way around but I think it needs to
be clarified and if we're actually using
a mobile phone to make calls and I think
it should be higher so
is that on the driver that's on the
drivers yeah so let me just let's shall
we just try and find the condition then
very quickly
that that's supposed to it's the sixth
down yeah
I'm not talking about I'm talking about
the actual condition that it's linked to
so just see what the wording is of that
of that is
because that might explain because I've
not used the full wording from the
condition it's just it might be a slight
for you you know a summary of it
[Music]
and you
you program anything and normally but
you can't
physically home with us that's a
punishable offense six points and
identify similarly with things like MP3
players uh and stuff like that you can't
you can't have electronic devices it's
not limited
it's just trying to find the condition
[Music]
oh yeah
okay
right so this it
is so the lights are seeing passengers
are not permitted to smoke in the
vehicle the life that she should also
must not
Vape or use an e-cigarette in the
vehicle drink or eat whilst driving use
any handheld device whilst driving or
allow themselves to be distracted in any
other way
um
so it must be that then I think
I don't think there's any other
reference to mobile phone
so would that be a better wording it's a
better wording yeah yeah absolutely so
if I replace that with that if they are
doing it and actually I think it should
be higher
okay I mean it's really difficult isn't
it you could be really picky about a lot
of these I mean some of the 25s like the
failure turned on time for pre-arranged
booking without reasonable cause I mean
for me I think that should be higher but
I mean and I wonder even why I've got a
25 category
discusses forever
think as I say it's a fluid document and
if
um if we found that
yeah we I think maybe we can review this
regularly with you
um because obviously we're going to
start using it a lot more and as as you
know we're gonna be talking about it
later
um and so
um we could develop it um with your you
know what you think is appropriate as we
go along
um I wonder too whether like in the
training I mean obviously when you when
you're doing this with the drivers it
might be interesting to get there
opinion on some of these as well as the
kind of would be quite interesting yeah
to see what they think
so if I change I'm going to change it to
use of any handheld device while driving
or I mean allowing themselves to be
distracted in any other ways
um
that's the condition
um
it could be anything good
but I'll try now I'll say I'll I'll
change the wording to to that so if
that's that you're happier with that and
what what's the penalty point now
you wanted it to be higher and then
failure to attend on time for
pre-arranged booking without reasonable
cause but I mean I think I think we
could probably argue about this forever
couldn't we yeah okay but I do wonder
about the 25s because I'm the one what
you know
if it's if it's something they're not
doing right why only give them 25
because it was a bit enough
well I mean we could give him all 150
questions
they would just come they would just all
come to committee
we're trying to avoid everything coming
to you
um
to question the start of how you've done
is I've tried to put waiting things
together myself and you spend days weeks
months arguing about the about arguing
about them
um as you say it's very subjective um
oh yes failed to
um attend regularly yeah yes so that
that would soon adult wouldn't it
um
three times yeah
um
is that the
um
yes
you'd prefer that to be 50.
I think it's mixed up that there was uh
when you're talking about eating the
vehicles if somebody had to buy a
sandwich
important
it seems to be like 75 but next week
you've got things like not much finding
information
so I want to just feel as if it's a bit
any help compared to the limits like
well I'm not saying this a lot it's just
like that particular one if you have a
bite of sandwiches
but next week
elections or not Billy Joshua investors
uh
people occasionally call an accident any
accident or concerned the operator or
so there's more you would have
considered to be a bit more serious down
50 but there's one or two just in the
same 75 back he just
um
drivers can obviously have appeal
against the points that are given to you
then um I think we would allow that
um without proceed it would initially be
an appeal to myself
um and that's obviously when we might
review some of these
um
but yeah they're often prompted by a
complaint by
a passenger well the driver was eating
while he was driving and it you know
sometimes that's where that's why we
sometimes have considered those those
you know more serious but
um
as I say there's so many of them going
through them it is very difficult to
um if you if you you have it in front of
you now if you want to
consider them further on your own Time
come back and say we want it to come
back
um to the committee you can because we
want to review them again or we could
um
schedule it to come back
I think we could agree
tonight with the various amendments and
then
I think if there are any of this if you
notice yeah
[Music]
a different thing was the I mean I think
we just asked earlier I didn't quite get
the answer it was the people that get
the points aware of how many points
they've got you know
yeah so they're written too yes so
they're written to and and advised that
um how many they've been given and how
long that those will remain on their
record so we're proposing as we haven't
done in the past this day on for like
three years on their record
so they get 25 points and then you know
if they don't do anything else in three
years they come off but if they
continually
um breach conditions those will be added
up for you know for it a rolling period
of three years
so it when there's a decision make on
the committee about somebody
a decision based on what they might
consider
well the last place that can appeal is
to you they can't appeal to a
magistrates because you've not revoked
their license or anything if it's an
internal monitoring scheme
well you're well I would say you're more
senior than me I mean if it could appeal
to me and I might say no
no I think it would probably start with
me and then
um I would probably liaise with you
and I'm the top and I would um then
liaise with you and then would decide
whether that's something that you'd want
to come to before the committee
um but ultimately it'll be initially for
me
um to decide
but it's not they can't appeal to the
magistrates court because you've not
you've not done anything to the license
yeah so I mean facts it's we you know
you can say to somebody well the option
would be to take you to committee and
they could the committee could take your
license away from you so this is just a
warning for you that you should behave
and you should comply with the
conditions because if you continue to
act like this and breach in decision
you'll be reported to committee and you
could
then lose your license
um on page four
um paragraph 1.8 which I have read about
40 times in the course of the last week
oh you can ask me
it says more than one accumulation and
penalty points in excess of the 150
Point threshold in any three year period
you'll normally result the subcommitter
revoking your license
I don't quite understand what it means
by more than one accumulation penalty
points in excess to 150 does that mean
you have to get 300.
yeah
so it could be remember one points
1.8
so we're saying I think what we're
saying there is that there might be
um two both several breaches all close
together that mean that they they also
cut two
they've accumulated 150 like you're
saying yeah 150 and then another another
batch of 150 oh some
well it sounds like that's what we're
saying doesn't it um
more than one accumulation of penalt
sports in excess of 150 pounds
I think yeah I think what it means is so
um
somebody can get 150 pounds points be
reported to you you decide we're just
going to get a warning this time we're
not gonna we're not going to revoke your
license but it's obviously staying on
your on your record for three years then
they get another 150 penalty points so
the report is back and what we're saying
is that that you'd be minded to evoke in
those circumstances
no no most
I think that makes sense
so I could reword that to make it clear
that
um
it's up to 150 you reported to committee
if you then accrue another 150
and you reported to committee you'd be
minded to revoke
yeah
we have no circumstances here is that
reminded I'm just trying to think
because I don't want to tie
the committee's hands but we might want
to have some certainty that
so let's keep it as that
it's just the first part of it then
um
policy that we have as well committing
yeah yeah
just come up with just the first line
that needs clarifying yeah right okay
I'm making out of that
Swiss amendments is paragraph 1.8 isn't
it
um yeah of the report
to clarify
for the no for the minutes I'm just
wondering if I just send
[Music]
um
the ones that we've amended
during the session so they can be
recorded
I think there was
um
a hundred I think we said
and also parking stuff been waiting or
picking up the truck and plus you just
want to take that
so I put it down a 75 I think we moved
to 75.
no you said you weren't sure
so I just said well I did say you know I
can put it up to 75 and then if it
through two occasions of that but if you
want to change it higher lower
foreign
[Laughter]
what we might consider
a little bit silly and then in the buses
in this hallway to something
but that would just be reported to you
and then you would make that
dissemination wouldn't you
um if you if you what if you want
um us to report anything where we think
you know failure to ensure passengers
safely to you
then by giving it 150 points that's
what's
you know we'll make an initial
assessment of that we think passengers
have been endangered and then um it will
be reported to you to consider it
full ultimately yeah you might say well
officers you're being really harsh yeah
we'll probably then
get some kind of
um idea of how the committee's thinking
in terms of what they consider to be
um
yeah
um
yeah yeah
wish that were there any more that
we didn't feel it had been agreed
were raised
this life
like texture
that I'm really intense
system so that will last
it was
the impact of operators it's very clear
that what can happen
to a driver
before
control
is
to accumulate
points from these popularity
they'll report it to you and you have
the same Powers as you do with drivers
and vehicle owners you can
to take not no action you can suspend or
you can revoke
description
yes haven't said
um not aware that we've ever done that
um
that because
every hour
um
I mean we can remove any of these um if
you don't want if you feel that that
would be
um
the thing is if we were to get a
complaint from somebody a memory
Republic who who said I wasn't told then
we can investigate and we can
well
but well our enforcement officers have
um yeah our Enforcement Officers
um
are doing operator inspections over the
next 12 months so
um we will see what comes out of that
inspection of those inspections
yes so we're going through the waiting
list at the moment so yeah quite quite
quite a speed so
um
there is also an Ask of government as
part of the Clean Air plan that's been
you know the proposals have been gone
back to government
that
um
they look at local legislation in terms
of
um out of area
drives and vehicles I mean obviously the
trade are concerned about that they
would want if that was introduced they
would want a long
leading period because obviously
they rely now on most of their Fleet so
we might be
licensed by another Authority so they
would want the
if that changed then they would want a
long leading time but
um it has been it has been asked again
of government as part of
what we propose for for greater
Manchester in terms of
um
the minimum standard licensing standard
term cleaner
okay
we need to draw this to a close enough
this is only aggressive questions
to make a decision
um do we
to make a decision based on
um
would I have to submit an offended
version for the chair to sign maybe yeah
I think I mean
except the ones that you've got there
come together to make another amended
version if you want these in paper now
and if you don't accept this version
then they all because obviously we still
do have deposit it's been ongoing
we've got an old we have a whole set
foreign
[Music]
with those amendments and if I have the
amendments in the minutes
um so I'll give those two
they're the next one yeah
so I'll set and then the amended version
notes to democratic services for
conclusion yeah
foreign